hawkeye and one division probably some
of the best marvel storytelling we've
gotten in quite a long time but the real
question is which one's better in case
you haven't read the video's title or
seen the thumbnail then you'll be
shocked to hear that in my opinion
hawkeye is the best marvel disney plus
series beating out wand division and all
the other shows welcome back to
streaming the galaxy i'm rocket riley
and in april of 2019 marvel announced
their slew of upcoming tv shows coming
to disney plus and i think we were all
expecting more low quality low budget
shows similar to agents of shield or the
netflix marvel series which are still
pretty great when things kicked off with
one division though everyone was
astounded at how absolutely amazing
everything looked and by the great
quality of the show the writing
production quality and big budgets
continued through loki and falcon in the
winter soldier it seemed as if all the
disney plus marvel series were gonna be
good if not great just like one division
then we got hawkeye and it just blew me
away by the way spoiler warning if you
haven't seen hawkeye or wandavision now
let's dive into all the things that were
similarly great on both shows first of
all i just want to applaud the writers
of both series for their ability to make
us truly care about all the new
characters added to the shows as well as
deepening our understanding of already
well-established characters for instance
wandavision made us actually care about
wanda's kids and their struggles and it
pulled everyone deep into an ago of the
heartless craze and hawkeye made us care
about one of my favorite new characters
kate bishop they do a great job of
setting up all the new characters
motivations as well as why we should
care about them also the writers were
able to take more time with wanda and
hawkeye to further develop their
characters since neither of them had
gotten much screen time before their
respective shows next i think it goes
without saying that both series have an
amazing production quality rivaling even
billion dollar films like avengers and
spider-man in behind the scenes
documentaries you can tell that these
disney plus projects take the same or
more time and effort to create than big
box office releases both wandavision and
hawkeye also bring us completely new and
unique concepts we've never seen before
one division takes us on a journey
through time from the view of a sitcom
audience while still telling a
spectacular story hawkeye puts a lesser
known character into a jingle bells and
grinchfield christmas series while also
pulling in characters from the greater
mcu such as yelena belova and even
kingpin also real quick i just want to
mention how excited i am to see how the
netflix shows are slowly getting wrapped
into the canon mcu projects as we saw
two characters show up in the mcu
recently matt murdock daredevil appeared
in spider-man no way home acting as
peter's legal counsel and wilson fisk
appeared in hawkeye as the menacing
character kingpin this just goes to show
that the mcu is going to be expanding in
ways that we might not have imagined
before okay now back to the main topic
of the video both shows have a
relatively consistent feel-good tone
throughout and i definitely appreciate
an upbeat story lastly both hawkeye and
wondervision had amazing twist villains
one division lulled us into a sense of
1950s and 60s security in the first few
episodes but then dropped on us that
wanda may actually be the villain of the
show since she trapped thousands of
people in a mystical hex in her grief
then we learned that wanda's neighbor
agnes is actually an even bigger villain
and it throws us for a complete
curveball hawkeye on the other hand
leads us to believe that jack duquesne
is the villain in the first few episodes
of the series but then we learned that
kate's mother eleanor is the real
villain killing armand and working
alongside wilson fisk's kingpin the
entire time now here's where things
start to differ between the two series
first of all i'm a huge sucker for
christmas stories so hawkeye gets a
point in my book right off the bat also
hawkeye adds in another character who's
been mostly separate from the greater
mcu up until this point ekko who's set
to get her own series in 2023 was really
great well one division introduced us to
several new characters it didn't do so
in the same way that echo was introduced
to us showing us her complete backstory
motivations and a full character arc
another big difference between the two
shows is that hawkeye completely
diverges from the typical marvel formula
especially in the finale most mcu films
and series like to end the story with a
big cgi filled battle and try to hint at
future projects before quickly tying up
any loose ends one division for example
had a big cgi filled battle between
wanda and agatha in between vision and
white vision they hinted at both the
upcoming film doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and the series
agatha house of heartness then they
quickly wrapped up all loose ends
hawkeye however deviates from this
formula giving us a much greater
character-driven third act to the series
while hawkeye also has a big fight scene
at the end it doesn't rely too heavily
on cgi and it actually carries some
weight bringing clint and kate together
as hawkeye partners also the finale
doesn't have any overt hints at future
projects which seem kind of like a money
grab to me lastly hawkeye just does a
better job of focusing on character wand
division while it may have had a more
unique story than hawkeye falls flat in
the area of character in the third act
focusing more on continuing wanda's
story in future projects rather than on
finishing up complete character arc like
we saw in hawkeye overall though both
hawkeye and wand division are some of
the best marvel stories we've seen in a
long time hawkeye barely beats out wand
division on just a couple of points
which actually make a pretty significant
difference in the show's finished
quality if you were looking for a
complete recap of the hawkeye timeline
after watching the show then check out
this video also don't forget to
subscribe and like this video and from
everyone here at stream in the galaxy
thanks for watching
[Music]